they are gone forever two suicide
bombers change the fate of nearly 100
people who are being carried to their
final resting
place Wednesday's attack happened at a
ceremony in Kerman to remember the US
assassinated General kasim sumani
Iranian president Ibrahim RI addressed
the crowd who gathered for the
funeral enemy is witnessing our power
all the world is feeling our power our
forces have the initiative time and
location police have arrested several
people in different provinces across
Iran but despite isol claiming
responsibility for the attack Iranian
officials have shown skepticism towards
the announcement and have promised
[Applause]
retaliation these killings are a
reflection of defeats that the arrogant
Powers have suffered over the past few
years by the grace of God the Revenge of
these killings will be taken but I would
like to say that already the Revenge has
happened the Iranian government wants to
provide people with some answers as the
region faces grave challenges and Iran
isn't an exception therefore it's been
looking into the details of the attack
and what response should follow I think
we should see all of them under under
one unique umbrella which is trying to
destabilize the region uh Iran is
located in this region so security of
the region safety of region is going to
fulfill the benefits of Iranian that's
why Iran and tyan is practicing sort of
strategic patience in the past wigs the
bombing in Kerman have shocked many
Iranians it's one of the worst attacks
Iran has seen in recent years and the
tight security measures here reflect the
amount of precaution the government's
taken to prevent another possible attack
Ali hasim Al
jazan make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer